le rugby-club de plaisir a repris ses
entraînements pour les enfants il y a
plus d'une semaine et pour les seniors
il y a quelques jours le jeu au pied est
l'un des exercices accepté du stade 3
par la fédération de rugby le stade iii
donc c'est un stade avec distanciation
des couloirs les joueurs peuvent se
faire des passes en ayant d'imparables
une désaffection des équipements et puis
bien sûr quand ils arrivent ils ont des
infections des mains et puis nous on
prend aussi la température plus en plus
les vestiaires ne sont pas utilisés les
séances ont aussi été réduite de 45
minutes au lieu d'une heure et demie
pour éviter les croisements entre les
joueurs les parents ne peuvent plus
accompagné leurs enfants jusqu'aux
stades
quant au sac ils sont rangés sur le côté
et bien espacées au niveau des
entraînements plus aucun contact
il faut donc pour les entraîneurs
trouver des solutions ils sont encore
petits donc on leur montre l'endroit où
doivent se tenir
pour ça on est obligées de mettre
beaucoup de plo chacun espacé d'entre 2
et 3 m pour vraiment qu'ils disent est
vrai qu'ils se tiennent éloignés le
maximum des adaptations nécessaires pour
le bon maintien des règles sanitaires
c'est différent je préférais quand y
avait les matches vous qu'on pouvait
bien se plaquer mais bon là on peut plus
on a fait un entraînement avec des coups
de pierre rajon des coups de pied aux et
des pompiers loin et ça change de
d'habitude parce qu'on fume moins
acte la plupart des exercices on les
modifier un petit peu pour garder plus
de distance qui change c'est que voilà
on fait surtout pas de matelas la santé
oms c'est un peu dommage pour les petits
mais bon c'est dans pas longtemps on
retrouvera les rugbys normal donc ça va
allez vous y croyez vous bien sûr il
fonctionnera et j'espère surtout les
compétitions devraient reprendre au mois
de janvier si les conditions sanitaires
le permettent